hey guys it's justine and today we have
the new iphone 12 here we also have the
iphone 12 pro
and some accessories we've got two cases
with of course the magsafe integration
we have the magsafe charger we have a oh
we have a usbc
20 watt charger since no chargers are
included in the boxes now
and we have one of the little leather
magnetic wallets that attaches to the
back of the iphone case
let's just get into this i'm currently
not in my studio i'm spending time with
my family so i kind of set up a studio
in this little basement area here so if
you hear a child crying or dogs barking
just uh you know i'm i'm doing my best
here we have the green iphone 12
and the pacific blue iphone 12 pro so
let's unbox them and get outside and
test these out
so here's the new slim boxes for the
iphones they're actually
much much thinner than the previous
look how thin this box is
12 pro here we go
whoa wow
okay first of all this blue
it's kind of hard to tell because this
room is a little bit darker and my
lighting might not be the best to show
this off
but actually no the lighting looks
incredible and this blue
looks pretty accurate this is really
really beautiful i'm so sad because i am
on this trip so i forgot to bring my
blue apple watch
and this i think is almost like a
perfect match to it
these squared off edges okay so i might
be getting the blue one i think that i
might get the blue
you've got your usb c to lightning cable
our sim card ejector four five freaking
g
the cool thing is all of the phones in
the current iphone 12 lineup
are 5g so no matter which phone you do
decide on you will
have 5g and of course they did not skimp
on the apple logo sticker i like that it
came in this like cute little tiny
little packaging
so here is the 11 pro max and this is
the iphone 12 pro
in the pro max it has a new telephoto
with a 65 millimeter focal length this
is up from the previous version which is
52 millimeters
the wide angle lens has a 47 larger
sensor which will give you increased
improvements in low light photography
and it has this new
sensor shift technology instead of using
the lens to stabilize the video and
photos
it actually uses the sensor to stabilize
this will also improve your image
stabilization as well
it's just the these lack of curved edges
just make it seem so sleek so this green
is very similar to
i guess it kind of looks like the ipad
air color it's more of a minty green
i actually really really like this mint
green color it's like a nice pastel kind
of a complimentary color
and now let's get into some of the
accessories one of the other new
features
in all of the iphone 12 phones is they
now have magnets built into the back of
the phone so with this you're able to
attach magnetic accessories
the magnets will also be built into the
iphone cases so they'll have pass
through charging and all the accessories
will work with cases so this is kind of
like the first look here
at the new magsafe charger so here's
what the packaging looks like
kind of looks like a little maze this is
also usbc
clearly we have a usbc trend other than
iphone being usb-c
right here it is the charger will it
magnetically
attach to the back
yep i wonder if this is strong enough to
hold oh
it is
it's like am i am i david blaine or
is my phone just magnetic it kind of
this is kind of interesting because
everyone thought that those circles were
going to be for air tags
in the invite but it seems as though
those circles were actually
magnets so here's the 20 watt usbc
charger that you can purchase separately
here it is in case you've
never seen anything like this before
time to charge
it's pretty strong magnet i will say
that oh my gosh it's turning on it's
turning on it's turning on it's turning
on it's turning on
hello this is the clear case so let's
open this up
whoa so it's clear but it still has the
magnetic ring around it
is nice because the 12 cases and the 12
pro cases will both work next case
pacific blue silicone these squared off
edges
it's really really nice you can see the
inside
where the magnet resides this looks
really good
check this out the one thing that i
thought was really cool is they came out
with this new material for the front
faces of the glass
it's called a ceramic shield so they
weren't actually calling it glass but i
mean
i don't i mean it's glass-like it is
supposed to be four times
more drop resistant which is when you
kind of think about it four times
stronger than the previous glass
is a huge jump our last accessory that
we have
is the iphone leather wallet and i'm
really excited about this new magsafe
feature because i feel like this is
going to bring out a lot of really cool
third-party accessories and
different types of mounts and all kinds
of really cool things that you can do
with your phone just uh go like that to
get your card out
we're gonna call this magsafe olympics
and when you attach the
little magnetic wallet accessory to the
back you can see a little white circle
appears
we're officially unboxed and now i'm
gonna go set these up and take them
outside and start doing some testing i
cannot wait to test out the dolby vision
hdr
this is gonna be so incredible if
there's anything you would like to see
me test out in a future video
leave me a comment below and hopefully i
can make that happen for you phone has
been unboxed i'm now shooting a video on
it
this is where i unboxed it at clearly
the unboxing remains
still remain let's go out and get some
pretty fall
dolby vision hdr shots on the new iphone
12.
[Music]
we're off on the trail this is the first
time that the baby has actually been
like in public wow
how excited are you she's been drinking
her water and then just
spitting it down her little carrier
[Music]
that was a lot of stairs and this dog
just pulled me so quickly down them
they're gonna go see the waterfalls he
might pull me in
can't be too sure
it's so pretty out maddie is really
afraid of the waterfall it's okay buddy
we'll save you
like look what a good job this does with
the highlights and the contrast
so cool
that's nice
[Music]
i'm out for a nice sunset run it's so
beautiful
not gonna lie i'm enjoying the iphone 12
pro
much smaller than the 11 pro box that
i've been having
fits very nicely right in the pocket
[Music]
all right we're at a 160 000 iso right
now shooting on the a7s3
pretty much pitch black outside right
now and i love to hear
just the nature sounds out here it's
really amazing i'm so excited to be
outside of los angeles
getting to make this video for you since
it is night one of the biggest upgrades
with night mode is it works on all
cameras
you guys i need that authentic reaction
i said that's a very nice picture
yeah i took it right now i even see
stars in it i know
it's like are you impressed that looks
yeah that looks like a picture frame
that's a nice picture breeze impressed
i'm impressed brian are you impressed
i'm impressed
i'm very nice
[Music]
so i've been taking some photos and some
video out here and i've been using both
the new 12 and the 11 pro max the iphone
11 is such an incredible camera so a lot
of the photos that i took they still
look
really really amazing on here the cool
thing is you can use night mode on all
of the cameras so i got a chance to
check that out
and i am incredibly impressed with these
photos
like they look so good one of the things
that i noticed is taking the front
facing
night mode honestly you can just use the
front facing flash and you'll kind of
get that same effect so i feel like if
you're gonna take a front-facing selfie
if you use that flash it's gonna still
look pretty good and also let's try to
test out a night time lapse
look at that look at that
[Music]
nature
farm friends
[Music]
so i just looked down and i was like oh
it's on 5g uw i've actually never seen
that before the 5g coverage still isn't
everywhere right now
so the fact that i just looked down to
be able to capture this is so exciting
okay oh my gosh so in comparison to
a 44.5 download on my att phone
29.4 upload 573 download
41.7 upload i'm going to come down here
and tether
to upload all of my videos from now on i
am 5g
look at all my friends
[Music]
all of the cameras on both of these
phones are really impressive
but the biggest difference is the 12
does not have a telephoto whereas the 12
pro
does so you're able to get those more
zoomed in shots and also different types
of portrait mode shots
as far as video is concerned you are
able to do dolby vision hdr on both of
these devices but on the 12 you can only
shoot in 30 frames a second whereas the
pro
you can shoot 60 frames a second
[Music]
wow it looks so pretty
uh can you believe we were just here
like a year ago doing the same thing
i am back for my trip which is really
exciting because i can show you guys the
difference in the blue colors from the
apple watch
and iphone 12 color so it does seem like
the
blue on the apple watch is a little bit
more of a matte color
but the color does look pretty similar
now the back is more of a matte color
but it is a little bit lighter than the
apple watch
in this different lighting as i move it
around it does seem to match pretty well
so i think that they look really great
together
here we have the iphone 11 the 11 pro
the 12 and the 12 pro so i just kind of
wanted to line these up to show you guys
what they look like all next to each
other
so this is the 11 and the 11 is actually
a little bit
bigger than the 12. you can tell that
it's a little taller
and it's also slightly wider the 12 pro
and 11 pro are also very similar sizes
but it is
slightly a little bit taller than the
11.
in comparison to the curved phones this
is
such a better feel like there's just
something about holding these that it
just feels
absolutely perfect also something that's
kind of cool is you can use the magsafe
charger
on your previous gen iphones it is
slightly magnetic
it's not as magnetic as the new versions
like it's so strong
you can hold your phone up but this one
no
it won't hold your phone up the one
thing that i have been really impressed
with
is the video quality obviously now with
this new dolby vision
there's gonna be a slightly different
workflow that you're going to have to do
in final cut
you are going to have to add this hdr
tools filter onto it so that you'll be
able to actually see what it looks like
by applying the hdr tools filter
in a timeline or a project that is not
an hdr project
you're still able to view what the
footage would look like when you export
it normally so working with hdr content
is something i think a lot of us content
creators are going to be starting to
work on in the future so i'm hoping that
youtube can really step it up to make
viewable hdr content a little bit better
because right now it's not the best i
want to show you guys the comparison
between the two boxes
so this is the iphone 11 pro and this is
the iphone
12 pro it's actually i would say
half the size
[Music]
make sure you guys are subscribed to my
channel and hit the bell so you'll be
notified when i post new videos i have a
ton of iphone content planned for you
guys and if there's anything that you
would like to see make sure you guys
leave me a comment
send me a tweet or post a comment on
instagram i will be doing a follow-up
video as soon as i get a chance to try
these out a little bit further and do
some more testing
until then i'll see you guys later